we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in with a question
that clearly is the source of much
confusion in general in the united
states
take a listen hey David I'm Austin
longtime listener first-time caller
from Pensacola Florida and I wanted to
get your take on the difference between
a Democratic Socialist and an actual
socialist thanks for any explanation
love the show have a great day okay good
I know that I've talked about this
before but any opportunity to clear this
up is a good one this is not about my
interpretation of Democratic Socialist
versus social democrat the difference is
democratic socialists are socialists and
Social Democrats are not Social
Democrats I know that a lot of them
don't like to use this term Social
Democrats are capitalists who want a
very well regulated version of
capitalism that takes the wealth created
by the capitalist system
disproportionately for the rich and
reallocates it to social programs and
government spending to ensure that no
one has a standard of living that goes
too low there are lots of comments like
we'll hold on a lot of Democratic
socialists aren't really advocating for
socializing the means of production but
there's still Democratic socialists well
no they're really not I mean okay we can
redefine terms we can just say the terms
have no meaning any more Social
Democrats might be socialist than
Democratic socialists might not but as
defined in the last hundred years Social
Democrats are capitalists and Democratic
socialists are not we can play with the
definitions we can change the
definitions but it's really important to
understand that we have a great bonus
show for you today
tons of stories from my vacation and a
bunch of other things to discuss with
you become a member in and get instant
access to the bonus show at join
pakman.com only two bonus shows left in
2019 and then begins it
properly begins an election year in just
a couple of days